how will U.S and German tanks help
Ukraine in its war against Russia Berlin
and Washington are sending leopard and
Abrams models to Kiev Russia calls the
move a provocation but will such a new
Weaponry change the course of the
conflict this is Inside Story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program I'm
Muhammad both Germany and the U.S have
agreed to send tanks to Ukraine Berlin
will supply its leopard twos and
Washington the M1 Abrams after resisting
for weeks Germany finally gave in to
political pressure it's also agreed to
allow other countries such as Poland and
Finland to send leopard two tanks from
their arsenals they're considered
essential for Ukraine if it's to take
back territory captured by Russia early
in the war president vlodimir zielinski
wants 300 tanks and has been asking NATO
member states for the weapons it looks
like he'll eventually get 88 from
Germany and another 31 from the U.S so
will this turn the war in Ukraine's
favor our correspondent Zain Bas Ravi
has this report
it is being called a game changer for
Ukraine Berlin agreeing to supply its
lever to tanks
speaking to reporters from a military
training facility in East Germany
defense minister Boris Pastorius is
pressed on when they will arrive in
countries can you get the tanks to
Ukraine at the end of the first quarter
of the year
that's what we are going to do yeah how
many months two three four I just said
at the end of at the end of March I
think is that in time because ukrainians
expect a Russian offensive to be
imminent all I know is that it is
earlier this week Germany approved the
delivery of hundreds of leopard 2 tanks
in EU arsenals to Kiev in the first
stage of the latest NATO push to send
more heavy weapons
what Ukrainian commanders say they need
along with more ammunition before the
winter thaw and an expected Russian
spring offensive
getting those Vehicles will improve
their ability to take ground but but I I
would be a little cautious about
assuming that with them they will
conquer the world the U.S is sending
dozens of its M1 Abrams tanks and the UK
14 of its Challenger twos they will add
to hundreds of Russian t-72s already in
Ukrainian military service
Moscow seized the development as Western
countries becoming directly involved in
the war and one that will lead to what
it describes as permanent escalation
the success of tanks on land in European
conflicts has historically relied on air
support and that is exactly what
Ukraine's President says it needs next
long-range missiles more artillery and
crucially modern military aircraft if it
is to take back the Skies over Ukraine
for Inside Story
on Wednesday President Joe Biden
announced the U.S will send 31 Abrams
Tanks to support Kiev
behavior of tanks are the most capable
tanks in the world they're also
extremely complex to operate and
maintain so we're also giving Ukraine
the parts and the equipment necessary to
effectively sustain these tanks on the
battlefield
when we begin we'll begin to train
Ukrainian troops on these issues of
sustainment logistics and maintenance
soon as possible
delivering these tanks to the field is
going to take time
time that we'll see we'll use to make
sure the ukrainians are fully prepared
to integrate the Abram tanks into their
defenses
a spokesperson for Russian President
Vladimir Putin says that Plans by the
U.S and Germany to send tanks to Ukraine
are a direct involvement in the war
Dimitri peskov said on Thursday that
both European capitals and Washington
keep saying that the delivery of various
kinds of Weapons Systems including tanks
to Ukraine absolutely does not mean the
involvement of these countries or the
NATO alliance in the hostilities ongoing
in Ukraine we categorically disagree
with that Moscow views everything that
the alliance and the capitals I have
mentioned are doing as direct
involvement in the conflict we can see
it growing
thank you
all right for more on all this I'm
joined by our guests in Moscow is Pablo
felgan Hower an independent defense and
Military analyst in Brussels is Teresa
Fallon director of the center for Russia
Europe Asia studies and in Berlin is
Olaf burnke Berlin director of Rasmussen
Global a political consultancy firm a
warm welcome to you all and thanks so
much for joining us today on Inside
Story Teresa let me start with you today
how significant is this decision by the
U.S and Germany to send tanks to Ukraine
and does this constitute a turning point
in the conflict
well there's been a great deal of
diplomatic wrangling going on even
within Germany there was a lot of
Divisions we saw Angelina bareback
making statements that were different
than Chancellor Schultz's so I think
it's a very positive signal that they
finally agreed to do this it would have
been much better if they had agreed to
do this months ago because we timing is
everything it will take a long time to
get this to Ukraine including the U.S
Abrams Tanks it will take you know a few
months to get those up there so the
spring offensive is coming and
everyone's quite concerned about this
but I think that at the end of the day
we have to remember you know Germany has
a lot of obstacles and that they are
making some movement and that's a really
positive uh sign let's remember the low
starting point they initially just
wanted to send 5 000 helmets so now
we've got them agreeing to send leopard
tanks which also means other countries
in Europe can send the leopard tank so I
think that this is a huge uh sign and I
I know that uh Ukraine uh president
zielinski has said he needs at least 300
so this is just starting so I think that
uh it's a very positive sign and I hope
that uh other countries will continue to
support Ukraine Pavel what's the view in
Moscow about all of this I mean how
concerned is Russia about the pledging
of these tanks and the delivery of these
tanks and are we going to see Russia
take take counter measures
uh well there's kind of two messages one
is more for the internal Russian public
Russian different military Specialists
connected to the authorities are saying
that these tanks will be destroyed by
the Russian military that this will not
change the overall balance of power not
so many of them and they can be
destroyed destroyed and of course they
can that's not the question but how
effective they will be that's an open
question the other message is going more
abroad that this is a dangerous
escalation that what the West is getting
involved and this is very dangerous
because Russia is a nuclear superpower
and if defeated on the battlefield could
they could do something drastic and
there have been different kind of
threats that Russia will destroy these
tanks it's not clear how and where
because Russia does not really have the
means conventionally to destroy them
until they appear on the battlefield
actually because Russia attacks deep in
Ukraine do happen of course but they are
not that hitting moving targets is not
really in the Russian capacity very much
in the Russian military so right now
they're threatening they're preparing
everyone's preparing for coming big
battles because it's understood that the
all the battlefield right now will be
decided how the further sort of the
situation in Ukraine is going to develop
Olaf um obviously that this was a
difficult decision for Chancellor
Schultz when it comes to Germany could
you walk us through how significant a
move this is you know to allow another
country to use German Leopard two tanks
to fight Russians in a war in Europe how
big a deal is that for Germany right now
it is a very very big deal specifically
for the party of the chancellor Schultz
or as Teresa mentioned not only the
greens also the Coalition partner the
liberal fdp was very supportive for
delivery of Tanks um for weeks now but
the SPD actually is perceived as the
party which of the LeBron actually was
always arguing for we need peace with
Russia we need conversations with Russia
or sort of the Diplomatic approach is
the right way to go significantly
there's
um the party the SPD published on Monday
a new white paper on the new foreign
policy and it's worth looking just in
the section where they Define their new
relationship to Russia if you read the
manifesto from the bonus tax election
one and a half years ago of the SPD it
still says there will be no peace in
Europe without Russia so for the very
first time now they made a 180 U-turn
and in this new paper they say we need
for peace in Europe a piece against
Russia so and they apologize indirectly
for all their false assumptions in the
past years towards Putin and his regime
so and this is one of the reasons why
the chancellor was so eager to be backed
by the solidarity of the US and his
European allies to do this only as a
team effort uh Olaf if I could follow up
with you I mean there has been so much
pressure on Germany to send these tanks
was Chancellor Schultz's decision
ultimately contingent upon the U.S
agreeing to send tanks is that what
really clinched the deal on this
of course he didn't say so in public but
from alter it is more than a coincidence
that the U.S government announced the
very same moment the he announced
actually that Germany will make pave the
way for the leopard too thanks not just
from Germany but a series I mentioned
also for many European allies
um that they will send Abraham tanks
even if we know that some of those have
not even produced yet and it might take
years actually to deliver them to
Ukraine so it was a huge deal and it
seems that the reason why it took so
long also
um and the defense minister Lloyd Austin
actually spent a lot of time in the
Chancery as we learned from from some
League Press News uh last week before
heading to Ramstein for that
conversation and in the end so the
German government made its way and they
are there but it's really very important
also for the uh for the German people if
you're looking to service form today
actually so people are backing a
majority the decision but they are also
very afraid actually of a further
escalation of the war by this decision
Teresa you know you were talking earlier
about what kind of equipment and Aid was
being pledged initially to Ukraine
versus what's being pledged now
um you know sending these M1 Abrams
Tanks to Ukraine this is a big reversal
of policy for the U.S and and many say
that this move would have been
Unthinkable just months ago I mean we
were just talking Olaf about the German
side of this equation but on the U.S
side was this decision by President
Biden made essentially to convince
Germany to send their tanks
as Olaf mentioned it's the the way it
was portrayed in the news the first
Germany announced and then shortly
afterwards uh President Biden announced
it so this is a reversal also in U.S
policy so I think that that sends a very
positive signal but it takes a lot more
time for the Abrams to to get to Europe
first of all uh they have to be built
many of them there aren't many in
storage or that can be just released and
as Olaf has pointed out you know this
will take some time also you know moving
them all the way to Europe so I think
that the fact that countries in Europe
want to release their leopards to
Ukraine is an important signal but
I think there is so much frustration
um in regard to Chancellor Schultz I
mean there was a lot of opposite
protests within Germany there's all
sorts of dialogue within Germany about
this and time is of the essence so as
Olaf pointed out the SP day is is
traditionally more friendly towards
towards Russia so I think that this is
also kind of the closing of an era and
with the announcement of the zeitenbenda
this you know change some people have
described it more as like slaloming down
a mountain it's not so much as a turning
point as you know kind of moving around
trying to find the center of gravity and
I think this war has lasted longer than
anybody in Berlin ever envisioned so I
think that as president zielinski said
he needs a lot more tanks he needs more
artillery he's going to start asking for
planes I don't know if that will happen
or not but I think it's important for
Ukraine to win at this point uh the
message is quite clear that the West is
United despite some kerfuffles and in
addition you know Russia's use of
threatening the use of nuclear weapons
you know the West is not being is not
kowtowing to that and that sends an
important message also to Beijing that
this kind of idle threat of nuclear
weapons is designed to scare people from
and make them uh have inaction that
there is some analysis that by Schultz
insisting that the U.S send the Abrams
it kind of signaled I mean this is one
analyst view that uh
that they're covered by the U.S nuclear
weapon uh by nuclear defense but they're
already covered through NATO so I think
that uh that's one analysis that Germany
wanted to have this kind of doing it
together with the US to show that
they're United and that they have
coverage because they're on the ground
there and they are fearful of any sort
of escalation and Russian rhetoric is
can be quite frightening Pablo Theresa
was just speaking there about Russian
rhetoric leading up to this moment and
in the past since the beginning of the
war in Ukraine
um the potential use of of nuclear
weapons
um tactical nuclear weapons uh and I'm
curious to get your viewpoint on this do
you think we'll be hearing more about
nuclear weapons going forward
will there have been pronouncements from
including Russian
officials like former president Dmitry
Medvedev who's now also still a high
official in the Kremlin uh talking about
the possibility of an escalation that
the defeat conventional Warfare would be
unacceptable and Russia is a nuclear
superpower and it can go
non-conventional that's what really
nuclear power has been nuclear weapons
have been used since 1945 as a deterrent
and for brinkmanship to threaten nuclear
possible escalation to find ways to
curtail uh conventional losses or at
least conventional threats so nuclear
blackmail is normal that's how nuclear
weapons have been used all the time but
actually going from there over the
nuclear threshold is a totally different
story actually using them because any
use of nuclear weapons would not bring
really Russia any political or military
dividends at all I'm not attacking
Ukrainian troops on the battlefield
could not bring much so they're not any
large concentrations and Russian troops
and the Russian territories nearby
attacking Europe or the United States
well then there's going to be a response
and then you owe out nuclear war that
will totally destroy Russia and actually
the Russian Nation will be wiped out so
I believe and that's most likely the
analysis that's coming from other places
and actually the Kremlin in the last
resort is also saying that this is not
really happening that the nature of the
operation is not changing so I don't
think it's good moving right now from uh
brinkmanship from blackmail to usage uh
probably I just want to follow up with
you about another issue um you mentioned
earlier uh that Russia is going to be
preparing for the coming big battles uh
and I'm curious do you believe that the
potential arrival of these tanks is
going to cause Russia to significantly
change its tactics on the battlefield
well of course the
the two account though there are many
factors happening there there's a lot of
talk in the west about the spring
offensive but that's not happening there
will be no spring offensive in March you
can't fight in those places in Ukraine
you'll just drown in month that's what
happened with the Russians last year in
March so if there's going there can be
uh escalation right now in the coming
week or two that's possible while it's
still cold and even there's maybe Frost
there down there and there could be
really big fighting already when things
begin to dry up that's end of April May
well technically maybe that spring but
that's already really the summer
campaign and if nothing happens drastic
right now in the coming two weeks that
means everyone's going to be uh moving
and thinking about the summer big sung
up Summer campaign and preparing forces
and reserves which is happening
basically right now there's also a lot
of disinformation being sent around by
all sides because war is deceit and even
everyone who wants to attack will will
try to convince everyone else if he's
not attacking uh Olaf the leopard two
tanks that have been pledged um it's
expected that they may start arriving in
in two to three months I believe
um is that timeline realistic because
it's not just about delivery of the
tanks it's also about training it's
about setting up Italians I mean is all
this talk right now about when these
tanks will get there is that actually
realistic do you think that's going to
happen according to this timeline
so what what have been reported
yesterday was that the training of
soldiers and the build up of the repair
facilities actually were started as of
right now so therefore I expect and we
we have training facilities prepared I
think in Poland and in Finland and other
places
um so and it takes up to four to six
weeks as I uh learned um for for
soldiers to be trained on the on the
leopard tanks
um the delivery yeah no one knows for
sure as you I think quoted before and
the the new defense minister said maybe
mid and March might be realistic
um so it's hard to say and as public
rightly said so the question is what
spring looks like
um this year in Ukraine
um and indeed um so no one knows but but
at least they will start immediately
with building up all the facilities
because it's way more than just
delivering the tanks it's also about
munition
um and all this reconstruction repair
facilities on the ground Teresa
President Biden has said that this move
should not be seen by Russia as an
offensive threat um but when the U.S
tanks arrive and when the German tanks
arrive at what point does this have the
potential to become an open and direct
armed conflict between the west and and
Moscow in Ukraine
well I think everyone is very cautious
about that I sit here in Brussels and
clearly it's not NATO getting involved
with this European member states or
other European states are getting
involved by sending support to Ukraine
so it's not a nato-led initiative so
that let's make that clear and I think
that you know we see central eastern
European member states completely
um uh supportive of Ukraine sending
whatever they can Estonia was sending
howitzers just to to show and try to
shame Germany into sending or agreeing
to uh send the leopard so I think that
it really depends where you sit in
Europe how you see this and I think we
should also you know look at it in a
positive you can look at the glasses
half empty or half full but the fact
that Germany finally did come to this
decision I think is really a very
important sign of continued support for
Ukraine but they need even more than
what's being sent like 14 leopards isn't
going to do the trick and so
um I love that word the Russian word for
General mud rasputitsa that Pavel was
speaking about about how difficult it is
to fight in the muddy spring uh there
have been you know there's a great deal
of concern about where Russia is going
to get these troops are they just going
to you know there's a clear issue of
lack of morale uh the ukrainians have
fought better than anyone imagined
they're highly motivated and maybe that
they can even scope down the the
training period for the use of the tanks
but they really do require a lot of
things that they are to win not just
survive so I think that there is a new
feeling that after the Ramstein meeting
that they have to win not just you know
know carry on indefinitely and I think
that the longer this goes on this whole
kind of China Russia
Alliance of convenience however you want
to describe it it is going to hurt China
over the longer term Olaf you you spoke
earlier about how difficult all this was
for Chancellor Schultz politically
um
at some point in the last few days he
acknowledged that many Germans are
deeply concerned by this decision to
send tanks to Ukraine I want to speak
Ramona about how much concern there is
in Germany about this and where public
opinion stands on it
no absolutely he made yesterday an
appearance in front of the parliament
and he closed his statement in which he
then announced that Germany will send
the 14 leopards to Ukraine by addressing
directly to the German people and saying
I am fully aware of your concerns and I
take this very serious so there you
could see that he has a very good
feeling maybe he's a bad Communicator
when it comes to his allies and and
political Coalition Partners but at
least so the people are backing um this
and if you and it was an interesting
switch in public opinion so while around
the Ramstein meeting end of last week so
there was a lot of criticism by
newspapers and others for why is he not
saying a word and why is he not
explaining himself so and over the
weekend actually that changed and more
and more commentators and also people on
the street I had talked to said I
actually appreciate that he's not
rushing into this because we're really
afraid of ending up in the next War uh
with Putin and you can see see this also
it's a very German domestic debate but
the conversation here in the beginning
we talked about defensive weapons versus
offensive weapons so weapons are weapons
so you can do anything with them so but
it was very important for the discourse
here to say okay we are delivering
weapons and that was in the very
beginning of the support for Ukraine
last year on February March saying we
are not entering a war we are not
interested in escalation so we're just
giving them defensive weapon they can
defense themselves with the leopard
tanks of course yeah they have been
delivered so president zielinski made
that specific
sentence saying we will use this so he
gave a special interview to German State
TV and said we will use your leopards
only to defend our country we are not
intended actually to attack Russia or so
this is important for the German
discourse and this is of course uh a
short constituency to be honest all
right well we have run out of time so
we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests Paula felgin how Teresa
Fallon and Olaf monkey
and thank you to for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
Facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash AJ Inside Story you can
also join the conversation on Twitter
our handle is at AJ inside story from me
Mohammad the whole team here bye for now
[Music]